[Music]
how do you do fellows kids I just got
off playing my favorite video game for
tonight with my favorite video stream
PewDiePie because how dare they yeah you
know did you see like the line on the
top right how it's kind of like going
don't you just love what companies and
people do they know their demographic
they understand the group that they
belong into and they don't try and tread
up tread outside it because I would just
be epic great so let's look at some
other people that does this very thing
so we learn to fit in properly our
fellow kids sub reading RC Cola we have
no plans to release any khofifah
flavored Cola
if you want the taste of incompetence
there are other suitors readily
available this is not a good marketing
strategy okay alright
excuse me guys I will just have to go
and buy some RC Cola right now whatever
there's two brands two for me to choose
from I always think to myself okay which
one of these brands have posted a
spongebob mean my physics professors
memes are improving every week
Isaac Sir Isaac Newton slaps roof of car
car
slaps Isaac Newton oh my god if only my
physics teacher used memes to educate me
then maybe I would know something about
physics isn't that right
oh lab Rita branded Twitter slaps roof
of car this bad boy can fit so much dead
memes in it by our cheeseburger
I love Wendy's she's so aware she's so
self-aware they are just in fact trying
to just sell the cheeseburgers no you
know as much as I appreciate the fact
that they're being honest
the most like and everyone loves Wendy's
Burger and I I wouldn't dare to even go
against Wendy's Burger but at the same
time this is just some lower paid
employee probably younger that fits that
fits the actual demographic of their
marketing to shilling for a giant
corporation with human via her human
rights violation allegations so maybe we
should be more responsible maybe we
should stop saying hey this meme from
this company is actually pretty epic Lee
and we should say you know what even if
they are self-aware about them selling
in me cheeseburgers that doesn't stop me
from seeing through their lives
[Music]
because lives are not epicly and human
right violations are not awesome why is
this the meme that everyone apparently
took car salesman
slaps roof of horse this bad boy can fit
nothing in it it's just a gift
I swear haha trust me I found this
legitimately hilarious reddit it's like
a joke on itself they they they're
exactly like these Wendy's posts they
like ha so self-aware right haha this
one was actually funny don't forget to
eat yearn for educational excellent at
all times papyrus and Comic Sans see
they definitely know what they're doing
they are trolling deliberately one of us
one of us he is preparers and Saints
those are the least
epically fonts everyone knows that the
new face of Philippi do you do fellow
kids what is it doing now I wonder
everything about that everyone is doing
something at the same time all right
ajit Pius doing right now oh you see if
this was deliberate I will buy all the
DiGiorno pizza I stayed because I was
manipulated deceived this horrible post
about why I stayed in these awful
relationships and DiGiorno ghost why I
stayed you had Bateson jordo had the
boss
if the aterna had the balls I would
actually be how do you do fellow kids
did join a pizza that's what I want in
my belly and not because I want to make
fun of these people for coming out and
saying why they left and stayed just
because I like pizza of course listening
to drivers excuses when they're caught
speeding
hashtag trash-talk nsw police force
[Music]
don't drive I forgot that's that's
Millennials favorite word trash you're
trash oh yeah you're garbage you're a
garbage human
I guess maybe because everyone calls me
that are you a millennial if so char
village is legit the best place for your
squad to stay try our 30 rooms our
hashtag blessed with super comfortable
beds and flat-screen TVs that are
totally on flea our prices are low
I have reception is 24 hours so we keep
it like I want to die
why does State Police Department post
memes why God why do they pose memes
stop just don't post anything
oh my god yeah Walmart did this
don't trust it the price is really low
with the first time he said Jesus Christ
I think you know I can't tell what's
worse Millennials or companies trying to
cop to Millennials what's worse the
lights on smith chapel look incredible
at night from Penn State Behrend oh yes
oh my god this is so cringe they didn't
even put the two dots over the Oh way
like these companies think they are
making like my jokes but they don't even
understand everyone knows it's or yes
epic fail
oh my god the cringe oh oh
Netflix us our best wishes to the royal
couple on their magical wedding and then
you got people saying okay I actually
like this yeah same to be honest I under
annika like a lot of us been showing up
on this up
sure mega-corporations coptic co-opting
meme culture to push their products it's
pretty or brilliant but god damn Wendy's
and Netflix are pretty loud some fire
lately edit hey guys
you know what I mean when I used a
really please stop correcting me because
I'm not changing it you pedantic
buttholes if this is ironic I will be
like okay fine well play I don't think
it is oh yeah
YouTube god bless
used to have this notification if your
it was kind of funny like number one
training video equals you yes your video
is on fire the number one spot on the GB
training pack is yours self awareness
from Xbox I am a branded social media
account looking for dank memes for my
fellow kids they know they like a super
simple way like how do they do this
oh my gosh Xbox I think I like Xbox now
because they are so self aware and as W
police always check your mirrors when
driving that's right everybody it's
important to know that you need to check
your BB C please never use the word lit
again
BBC News oh my god tagged actually funny
that's alright everybody that was
actually funny oh boy
nothing like a 2012 meme everybody what
does the Fox say
oh it says to not chew gum at the
library warning if you chewed gum at the
library you will be asked to stop hey
alright sorry I don't mess with 2012
memes you see you know what I guess this
is the thing if this was ironic that
would be epically but then again even if
it's it is ironic it is not epically
that's the paradox of memes everybody Oh
New Zealand New Zealand I do like some
of them I'm not gonna lie
this is real is this even real I like
how this one doesn't get there actually
funny approval I think that's the thing
companies can only be funny if they're
unintentionally funny that's how it
works
writing is sensational I think it's a
it's time to anything don't get me wrong
I enjoy a good life and sometimes you
know they they are good I'm not gonna
lie sometimes companies do pull off a
good memes and there's something
respectable about that just from the
matter-of-fact how extremely cringy most
9 out of 10 are they all promote this
idea of staying woke and being so real
but in fact but just don't forget kids
companies aren't your friends
they will never be your friends and even
if they know they aren't understand
change the fact my name is Peter pie and
you guys are my best friends that's
right I'm changing the name from brows
to best friends remember to buy the
merch
[Music]